- And I play Peter's assistant
and she's this weird,
quirky, bubbly, but
very, very weird person.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who is really shy-
- That's fun to play.
- And is like a, a very
much a perfectionist.
And so she doesn't want
people to hear her sing
until she knows it's perfect.
Which I can very much relate to (laughs).
- I was gonna say, are you that person?
- I am that person.
I'm way too much of a control
freak and a perfectionist.
So, I very much related to that.
And yeah, it's all about
Bumper trying to win a thing
called German Unity Day
concert for a record label.
- Oh my God.
- [Sarah] Its a lot of fun.
- I'm gonna love it.
- [Sarah] It's so great.
- Okay, let's see a clip.
Here's Sarah in Pitch
Perfect, Bumper in Berlin.
♪ Staring at the ceiling ♪
♪ I am wide awake ♪
♪ In a city of strangers ♪
♪ Who don't know my name ♪
♪ Everyone's trying to make it ♪
♪ Trying to leave something ♪
♪ And since I was here for a minute ♪
♪ For a minute ♪
♪ And I did my thing ♪
♪ It's all in my head ♪
♪ It's all in my heart ♪
♪ The light always find a way
to shine through the dark ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- I had, I had heard
you sing on something.
I had not heard that.
I knew you were good at
both, but oh my gosh.
That was beautiful.
- Oh my God, Kelly.
Gosh, thank you so much.
- That was beautiful.
And I love that you did
a perfect representation
of kind of being nervous,
and this person got put in this position.
It was so acted out so
well. That was so beautiful.
- Thank you. Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Kelly Clarkson said
my voice is beautiful.
- No, your tone, your vibrato,
that was so beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
- That's so fun for you.
I love that you get to like
act and do your thing there
but you get to also express
this other talent that you love.
That's really good.
- [Sarah] Thank you so much.
- Wow. I woulda press my button, girl.
(Sarah screams)